so Dave yes yes
everybody's watching everybody's seeing
what's going to happen you're seeing
different names you're seeing different
you know centered races house how did
you think that they went well first let
me just say as we were all here in
Florida everyone here lives in Florida I
take it yeah California call me for you
oh I know I know and he loves it there
good luck with that but he lives in
Bakersfield which is a different kind of
encounter all right we're Republicans
Beggars I once saw an outdoor Frankie
Valley concert okay there you go over
there
um well look as a Floridian as a new
Floridian as you said I'm here I got
here on December 17th 2021 I will never
forget the day and the moment that I
landed here uh you know Florida is so
set up so everything here is right this
is what America is supposed to be this
is what competent governance is this is
what Freedom's all about we are set up
so well here and this will continue and
and I tweeted out yesterday Lee zeldin
who just did something incredible in New
York despite losing move down here let's
take all the confident people I mean it
I really mean it let's just how about we
just open this place up for all of the
competent people let's get all of the
competent workers all of the competent
thinkers and money managers and
everybody we've got land here you know
we have a housing problem here but
there's plenty of land down in Homestead
and across the Panhandle there's land
let's start building do some great
infrastructure things so I'm feeling
great about Florida the rest of the
night I mean we still don't know what's
up with Arizona so it's a little kind of
wishy-washy but it certainly didn't go
the way that I think it would have been
best for America for a free America
let's put it that way but by the way you
know zeldin you know the status first
time I think in two decades or it was a
four decades that a governor race was
that closest the closest race in four
decades to lose by only five points you
got to give them respect on nobody knew
him two months ago nobody had a clue who
this guy was some people thought he was
like a you know what do you call it one
of these heavy metal guys
keep rocking yeah but uh uh so so okay
so now the question the main question
everyone's asking and you know you've
been asked this you know yourself and
you know so look the reason why this
happened is because what America doesn't
want is anybody that uh Trump endures
is you know it's not looking good it's
because of his involvement and the
stories coming out he blamed his wife
you know these articles that are right
and saying he was losing his mind
yesterday you know he was livid he was
screaming obviously that's an Insider
story but even New York Post posted
something today talking about maybe it's
time to move because what America is
showing is Florida the guy won 62 out of
67 counties it's a lot 62 out of 67
counties and the five that he lost by
the way all had record numbers for
Republicans so Broward I think was up by
12 points for Republicans he lost he won
in a certain sense yeah so so what do
you what do you think about that do you
think do you think it's at it's a point
where you know it's time to move on or
it's not going to happen you have to
know that he's going to be running and
there's got to be a strategy and he is
going to call him out and it's not going
to be pretty and DeSantis should still
run and they got to go through it and
let the Republicans decide who they want
as a candidate what do you think I think
just before we get into the Trump thing
specifically I think we just have to
accept that probably 40 of the country
just wants more nonsense they want more
government they want more lockdowns they
want more control over their lives they
want higher taxes they want bad
governance and bad schools they they
have been so brainwashed you know the
NPC means the non-playable character
character meme they want it and it just
is and we can do the best we can to to
bring better ideas to them and and break
some of them but I think we just have to
accept that that that's sort of separate
then did Trump really move this thing I
don't really think this thing was about
Trump I mean the Trump the real Trump
people did not do that well I mean the
fact that Oz lost to fetterman I mean
because I mean Penman is whacked out but
fetterman can't speak right he literally
not only does he have all the worst
ideas like all of the worst socialist
big government ideas and release people
out on this you know the criminals back
into the streets and all that but the
guy cannot speak and then did you see
last night on MSNBC they actually had a
panel on whether John fetterman should
be the nominee for president in 2024. it
is a televised mental institution over
there yeah yeah that he should be the
one that he should be the nominee that
he should run yeah but like how do you
how does Oz Lose to that guy like
there's something there other than like
they all just want lockdowns they're all
idiots what Acts actually happened
though like go deeper into the fact of
like how does Oz a very well-known
character lose to a literal Weekend at
Bernie's character yeah he wasn't look I
I actually kind of like Dr Oz and I
think he's sort of I think he's kind of
like you Adam I think he's kind of like
a disaffected liberal who's woken up a
little bit and he's kind of he's kind of
getting there I was here what about what
it's about eight months so I got to see
how far we've dragged you because I
dragged I dragged Mar I did two hours
with Mark exactly I watched the whole
thing I want to talk about that for sure
um but Oz just wasn't a great a great
candidate but but it's a moot point that
anyone in their right mind voted for
fetterman that you thought this is a guy
we should send to the Senate he can't
speak you know what I mean that's not to
diminish the stroke and all that but
like come on it has to be better than
this we're sending the guy in the hoodie
who can't speak let's roll so what all
the craziness taking place I believe
future looks bright if you believe
future looks bright get your latest
Future looks bright hat of valuetaining
it says future looks bright here future
looks bright here we got him in white we
got them in Black we got them in red our
black on black sold out these are about
to sell out if you haven't ordered one
yet we had a person in Michigan but one
then he bought three then when those
three people weren't in the office they
had to order 58 of them because people
wanted the future looks bright hat
especially during times like this
because ain't nobody's saying future
looks bright toward your future looks
bright hat click over here and to watch
the entire podcast click here take care
everybody
thank you